i think the the crucial thing is to
recognize that we've got a
a new variant that uh is requiring extra
special vigilance
and um we will do everything we can
to to keep the virus under control and
people should be in no doubt that the
government will do everything that is
necessary
but i must stress that at this critical
moment it's also vital that
people keep discipline i think huge
numbers of people
are still following the the guidance i
think
some people understandably are becoming
frustrated
impatient and they're not following it
in the way that
they should most basic things hands face
space
they really really matter now
particularly
with this new value do you think there's
evidence people that more people are not
following the rules
i i wouldn't say that that i think the
public have
just been fantastic in the way that
they've tried to
to follow the guidance and done their
their very best but i do think obviously
as months and months go by
people's uh patience understandably
starts to
to wear thin so all i'm saying to
everybody is look you know we've got
tough tough weeks to come now it's
clearly we've got as you as you rightly
say we've got
the uh the virus really surging it's
it's vital in addition to the
the tough tearing that we put in the
further measures that we may very well
have to take
it's vital that everybody now does
their bit together on those further
measures this morning the health
secretary said the old tier system is no
longer strong enough
so what further restrictions will be put
in place well i'm going to
obviously ask you to to wait and we'll
we will be producing uh everything that
we think is necessary to
keep people from spreading the virus if
you think about it we've already got
a lot of the country in uh in tier four
some of it in in tier three
what we've been waiting for is to see
the the impact of the
of the tier four measures on the on the
virus it's a bit unclear still at the
moment
but i think there's you know if you look
at the the numbers
there's no question that we're going to
have to take uh tougher measures and
we'll be
announcing those in due course and
primary schools um some have stayed
closed today despite your assurances
that it's safe they're effectively
ignoring you
um aren't they simply doing now what you
inevitably tell them to do
and close in the coming days i think
it's very important to understand that
back in back in march uh one of the
things that
i look back on uh with with the greatest
misgivings was the closure of
of primary schools because it's so
important for
for young people to to get an education
and the
the different the difference it can make
to their lives being in school and not
being school at that age
is really very very important that's why
closing
primary schools is a i think for all of
us it's a last resort
and uh postponing the opening of primary
schools
is a is a last resort and that's why
we're looking at everything else we can
possibly do
to avoid that given the the the social
the uh the the damage the educational
damage that that is done
um what i would say to to teachers is
first
and to everyone to parents thank you for
everybody for for the immense work that
uh you've done to to make schools safe
and i would i would stress that schools
are safe
and as you know the risk to to kids
is very very small and the risk to
teachers and obviously we'll do
everything we can
to to protect teachers but the risk to
teachers is
is is no greater than it is to to
anybody else in any other
uh line of work but we'll do it i thank
them for what they are
what they're doing so my message would
be look
we have a surging epidemic that the
reasons for
uh wanting to keep schools open i think
are very very powerful
what you've got to to look at is the
the extent of the epidemic in the areas
where it's really
surging and whether not because schools
are unsafe but whether you can
actually do more to contain the epidemic
uh with
by by closing schools as well but
there's a doesn't that
that's the issue is there a trust issue
here that you're saying to them look
it's safe the government is saying stay
open and they are in large numbers
across the country ignoring you and
closing so
they're not they don't trust you when
you say it's safe well
i think i think that that's not rhyming
schools are safe
and uh huge numbers of schools have uh
have opened and i think that's i thank
them and for what they're
doing the the issue is not the safety of
the schools it's very important to get
this across
the issue is the extent to which
the mingling of kids in schools
by putting lots of households together
causes the the epidemic to to spread
even faster and
alas that pro that's why in some parts
of the country
uh we've had to ask primary schools as
well to postpone
their their return and i don't want to
do that but it is
necessary and we will keep all measures
under review as it happens it looks as
though
uh secondary schools probably pay more
of a role in the spread of the epidemic
than
than primary schools uh so we'll have to
look very hard at
what we do with uh with secondary
schools later in the month
and they could stay close beyond january
18th do you think
but i do want to stress for everybody
the the the efforts that we're making of
course
as a government to try to keep primary
schools open i understand people's
apprehensions are not
i would just you know pay i would say
respectfully to them i i think it's
wrong to say that schools are unsafe
schools
are safe the anxiety we have as
a government is about the role of of
any uh of schools or any any activity in
spreading the disease and that's why
i would really ask people to focus now
as we roll out the vaccine
on what we can all do to stop
transmission and what we can all do to
follow the guidance and very quickly
before i ask you on vaccines do you see
secondary schools potentially staying
close beyond january
well we're obviously going to keep
everything under under review
um education is a is of huge importance
for
for young people it's a it's a it's a
real
loss to them if they don't get it and
that's why i think as a society we've
done the right thing
uh to put such emphasis on it and we
will look at everything else we can do
in you know most of the countries
already in
in tier four we'll look at everything
else we can do uh to contain advice but
we will take the necessary decisions to
protect
public health on vaccines obviously
we've waited nearly a year for this
moment we've planned
um for this moment for a year so why
does the nhs not immediately have the
capacity to administer
um the two million doses a week that
you're calling for well that's
completely untrue we do have the
capacity the issue is
to do with the uh supply of the
of the of the vaccine and now you've got
a it's not so much a manufacturing
issue that is is part of it it's uh it's
also that each batch
needs to be properly uh approved and
quality controlled
uh because uh this is a it's i mean
it's fantastic news that we have a
vaccine and we've got two vaccines we
have
several vaccines coming down the the
truck and actually i think
um it's been amazing that it's it's
taken as little as a
as a year to to produce this but you've
got to make sure it's
it's uh properly approved before it goes
into people's arms and
that's what we're doing people will be
asking where's the big grand plan to get
this done
going beyond hospitals getting the army
involved getting
as many people as possible to get as
many vaccines out as humanly possible
where is that big grand plan prime
minister yeah i'd be in no doubt there
is a massive this is the biggest vaccine
rollout in the history of
of the country and i know that um uh
you know your viewers may be aware that
uh that
this country has already done uh well
over a million uh vaccines
and more than the rest of uh europe put
together so
uh you know i don't think we're being
slowed by international
uh comparisons but there is a massive
ramping up operation
uh now going on and you mentioned the
the army you mentioned
uh all sorts of uh volunteers all that
is is going to be involved but
the the what they call the rate limiting
factor is now not a supply of
uh a vaccine that they we want that to
go faster
uh it's it's getting them properly
tested
getting them uh to the uh to the nhs and
so so the rate the rate limiting factor
is not the ability to distribute
uh the vaccine it's not the shortage of
staff to get it into people's arms
it's getting it properly tested and
probably either and
you know that will ramp up in the
in the weeks uh ahead but
as i as i said yesterday it's difficult
to give
exact numbers today except that it will
be tens of millions by
the end of march as soon as we have
a some you know some better numbers
to to give you about the millions of
vaccines and
we've already committed to two million a
week as you know
then of course we'll be giving them when
will we get that first two million a
week when we hit that first
as soon as as soon as we can give you
that day do you don't think it will
happen next few weeks i think we'll make
until february march till we're doing
that
i'm not going to rule that out but we'll
be we'll be giving you more more detail
in the course the next
few days